[Music]
in put on blast news a-hole submitted by
education connection songs education an
Instagram account is calling out church
pastors for wearing expensive item
that's awesome that's funny because we
think in the microphone hmm funny
because this has been happening and
they've never really been called out for
now we got some media to do it we can
drag these can go viral so here is this
Instagram page called preachers and
sneakers
it has 142 thousand followers and it
posts photos of preachers I don't
understand mega churches oh my god
that's not right yeah I don't understand
this [ __ ] but I usually supposed to be
poor if you're a pastor I don't think
Donald's with the [ __ ] yeah Rockstar is
Delta yeah I want to buckle now very
valid I've been wanting that belt that
one I got this knockoff one they're kind
of like like kind of like similar it was
$10 are you gonna buy fake one
whatever oh yeah I didn't look too hard
if you guys want to get me anything from
a birthday I want a Versace one with the
line that's up please Medusa I heard
they're all sold out they don't want
anything happy birthday
any birthday plans ready yeah I just
thought of the present right now you
didn't have a party you can't get
present no no no this weekend is my
party in my heart I mean I'm with you
guys
I'm just happy yeah a present of mine
but then in the other video you see
don't want anything you just want them I
don't really care yeah I mean it's not a
big deal if you get it I mean if you get
it you get it right yeah laughing Gary
oh my god you sound like Nicki now what
did i do what did I do
what was so Aries about it going back
and forth and I saying like you wanted
something but like you know I don't
really actually want to know I like to
say things like I mean it but I don't
cuz it's funny so you're a liar you know
what my gift is getting a reaction out
of people
that's an Aries thing actually every
areas I don't like to get a reaction all
the time I'm a Capricorn the breath for
a minute time oh yeah what the hell did
y'all grow up religious yes very church
three times a week free yeah Southern
Baptist okay well summer practice that's
one of the worst ones don't you think
it's what my grandfather was one of the
first-ever televangelist so he would be
like on TV and be like snakes come out
here for a well child said it at the day
and what do you do is he would dress my
mom and her brothers and sisters up
interact like rap not drag in
raggedy-ass clothes and bring them on
stage and be like send money to the
church and then he would pocket it he
was a criminal his name peter Popoff no
okay crazy like the vodka yeah no if you
was a televangelist guy that was pretty
famous and he got caught for certain
things
Thanks so your he was a part of the
mother yeah yeah so you don't like him
yes we don't talk he doesn't even I bet
you these guys look up to your grandpa
probably they're like they know that he
was a pioneer he did all that I think
it's like hot like these must all be
mega church preachers or anything like
it yeah like oh I don't know that cuz
like people who are super religious also
tend to be like kind of up in the upper
echelon you know like bless your heart
go to church on Sunday
women country club women maybe yeah I
think that's a southern thing like
southern conservative or Bible Belt area
like super rich you know
old money kind of thing yeah and their
defense what I was thinking too is like
I think there's churches for there's
churches for different communities so I
can also see if like these guys were
churches in a baller-ass community where
people give hella money and the people
that go to that church might even delay
hey just buy these sneakers like they
want they don't they want their pastor
or a preacher to be at their level to so
they might have even gotten encouraged
to live this lifestyle but then everyone
else is just regular so we're looking at
them like how dare you but maybe all the
people he's serving is telling them
tonight that you projects things onto
people to make them more of a good
person no just thinking for like it
angels you feel you feeling all the
holes like all the holes that are
missing you're like wait let's give them
a benefit of doubt but would you take
like religious advice about like your
life from a man who's got like I don't
believe in any religious people do you
believe I'm here that's why I believe
yeah yeah I guess I don't know if I was
like trust a man who's more stylish than
I advise on my family's being like give
up materialism and give the church your
money and then they're rocking light of
your income 5,000 dollars sneakers like
there's a prosperity church though
[ __ ] wild religious Scientology is
like 90 percent yeah that's like your
life but there is a prosperity gospel or
prosperity church where they promote
like if you pray for it you want it you
deserve it kind of thing and then so
everyone's buying [ __ ] marketing it's
that's what it kind of seems like yeah
but they that's what they do I mean
David talks about it all the time he's
like I hate those churches
yeah because David's a Christian friend
or one and only if there's very few out
here in LA yeah I was raised Catholic
and I was talking on the break about how
we still give up stuff for Lent but we
don't I'm not Catholic anymore you do it
out of like guilt no I do it out of a
challenge like I just like the challenge
of giving up something for 40 days you
should
masturbation dude see if you can pass
the challenge do it one I'll do that
next year I'm always trying to think of
what what's a good one to give up like a
really hard one like I like what you
give us here this year I gave up phone
games because I was using them to
procrastinate a lot I must be hard yeah
it was it's really hard and especially
like when you're waiting there's this
game called threes I looked at you cuz I
was like are you serious
I don't play phone games but I see how
addicted you are so much yeah I must be
right when do I play other than night
time because I want to get bored so I
can follow since we gotta go back to the
article the first sign of addiction is
denial I just recently started playing
phone games and it's helping me relax
and think clearly but it's supposed to
be like aren't the space stimulating
your brain like you say it to be bored
and fall asleep doesn't it really like a
word game and then after a while I'm
like oh yeah those are boring yeah I
like the ones that like I just have to
keep playing cuz I want to know you know
yeah mmm did I play to go to sleep - the
same word one and it's it makes me
really tired yeah I bring the tired cuz
it's like a jumbo like they give you
like six letters and you have to just
come up with words and then after a
while I like Scrabble it's kind of like
a Scrabble okay
so am i addicted no no no no way I love
the strategy part of Scrabble were you
trying to get a word to get like a
triple word connecting to a double word
score and like you like it I like the
strategy sound so addicted phone games
because you don't need another person to
play with you oh that's the part I miss
[Laughter]
[ __ ] Monterey Park combined and this
is far yeah told you everyone lives in
Hollywood I live closer to Hollywood
than I do Monterey Park well la locals
live outside of LA but you're trying to
get non la locals to be here sure I know
yeah I know what happened we just
started here and we just never left yeah
we should we should have sponsored by
said matcha thank you very much she's
not in Hollywood or the valley I know
right might be going there some other
office it's downtown LA oh really why
don't you use that one Oh cuz these guys
don't like you they don't like oh that's
cool they like this one yeah we kind of
[ __ ] it has character their stories it's
very personable we [ __ ] up on the set
because we made the set look like a TV
set and it looks really in not personal
and everything for them but really it
was to inflate our ego it's like the
priest buying the easies people like
doing anything about it like are they
like this is my most favorite account to
follow now they're just like wow I love
when people get caught up for their
[ __ ] because it's actually pastors
are sending photos of themselves so they
could be featured on this page this
world is so background wait so they want
the show they want to show off and then
but then this page is to call them out
exactly but they see it as like cool
like their dude I know ex pastors that
they're kind of like young they're like
our age they used to be pastors but
really they really liked the performance
and like being the center of a 10
part of the passive thing yeah and so
now they're off trying to be
entertainers and stuff but they really
that's what they liked about it was the
having everyone's attention that's true
for my uncle's a pastor he's a
narcissist
[Laughter]
you know cold-start
know if you find one guy he's really
cool and you're like yeah I want to do
it he's doing he's the coolest guy in
the room I'll go do that so there
through them I will die for him if we
oppose my uncle he would [ __ ] us up yeah
that's usually don't you watch
documentaries with the cult they always
get [ __ ] in the ass and they're always
bisexual right and they always come out
later and they're like um they're like I
didn't even know that was weird at the
time I just thought that that was we're
supposed to do get brainwashed yeah they
really didn't but they always go with
but [ __ ] guy or girl yeah that's got
to do with some like pathologies like
sodomy isn't that like between God and
me any redheads and the dog what sodomy
ain't gotta me you never know
I'm like blue head over here ya know
it's out of me is between God and me Oh
because you could still [ __ ] the
button B except ya cuz you're not you're
not you're still a virgin right yeah
yeah yeah yeah I did that my 16th
birthday I was like trying on your 16th
birthday yeah because I was trying to
save it till marriage and I thought you
know well I'm doing the boyfriend for a
while and when I want to save sex till
marriage so yeah did you do it ain't no
cleanse before cuz that's what he's
known and it didn't even happen because
he put it in and I was like get it out I
hate it I have never seen it'll happen
where it doesn't end in tears
yeah I've seen it happen do you know
some of my friends though are like
obsessed they're like you just gotta
relax and let it happen like I'd rather
be stressed out with a tight butthole
thank you
[Music]
[Music]